here we
go
all right ronnie ordonez
what's up derek kovac what's up simone
what's up
everything nerd wf mobility no carlson
over to burger bucky
yeah jayashree needa
malik for khan ronnie what's up
everybody how are we doing hey brianna
how's it going
was that you that i saw all my tick tock
that commented kind of looked like you
good morning winter soldier or i mean i
guess it is good morning it's 12 46
where i'm at right now
sassy pants what's up how's everybody
doing
who's ready let me make sure the sound's
working
we're doing it doing it doing it let's
turn this down
cool cool cool it looks like
everything's good to go right now
looks like everything's good to go all
right let me know if there's any
problems i just checked on my phone it
sounds like we're doing pretty good
uh hey thank you so much for all the
what's that that was your tick tock oh
good good round that's what i thought
that's what i thought
great to see you on there i'll do better
episode ticked out guys
um i know i just kind of started it but
i want to do better
i actually posted one like last year i
think in like november or something like
a long time ago
and then like i never posted one after
that so yeah
um you're still not okay from one
division i exist
i i'm excited to see you know where it
goes white vision i don't want to do
i don't want to do spoilers for that in
case somebody here hasn't hasn't seen it
you know so
jr superhero geek 100
slacking veteran hey the flute blogger
what's up man
how's it going
how is everybody tonight are we ready
for the falcon and the winter soldier
let's do it hey drove yeah i remember
you from uh
the watch party today on cosmic culture
for uh the snyder cut
which by the way was pretty freaking
good
but that's like a testament to like
marvel hold on some somebody said
volume up can we hear me
sounds like you can hear me just fine
okay yeah cool we're sounding good we're
sounding good we're sounding good
so it's so funny because a lot of people
have been asking me
like about about cameos and
uh you know uh i wish everything i've
only seen the first episode
um just like one division i saw the
first three episodes and there was nine
episodes of one division
and there's only six of falcon in the
winter soldier um
oops so i i haven't seen all the way
through it you know i haven't seen the
finale anything like that i've only seen
the first episode the one that we're
about to watch right now
and it's pretty freaking cool
um i don't want to say anything i don't
want to say anything
i i don't want to say anything uh ashton
yes the snyder cut should have been the
original and i was just about to say
the snyder cut and the fact that it's
successful is uh
is a testament to marvel studios
because marvel did their movies first
they introduced everybody first gave
everybody their time went through their
stories
and then they brought them all together
so the first justice league didn't
really do that
but the standard had four hours and it
actually introduced the characters and
talked about their backstory and that's
why it was better
that the story was just better but
that's that's like
what marvel did so right
that's what they did so right like i
it'd be so weird if you just had an
avengers movie and you didn't have
uh iron man introduced by himself
and black would have introduced an iron
man thor got his own movie
captain america got his own movie the
whole kind of got his own movie wasn't
the same
same actor but he got his own movie
so uh when's it gonna start
uh it's in 10 minutes
10 minutes it should be going let me
make sure we got everything in check
here looks like we do
let's take a look over here on this
screen
so here is
it's not up yet oh whoops
go back back back yeah it's not up yet
i'm gonna
i'll go ahead and kind of show you what
we're looking at here
actually let's
so it's not up yet i don't
i don't see it anywhere all the epicness
of the mcu
one division so i don't see it yet
but i also put this down because
occasionally i am going to show
like a clip or two something like that
you know i can't do it the whole time
obviously
because of copyright issues i hope
everybody understands the same as the
one division watch party guys i'll show
you a little bit of footage
i obviously can't stream it because you
know
copyright so
well i saw somebody say wtf moments
falcon should have his own
backstory in a movie it's very cinematic
like
you'll see the action scenes are really
really good it's not any different than
an mcu movie like
and kevin flagging the cast they've all
said you know a bunch of different times
like
they were asked like what's kind of the
advantage of disney plus it's like okay
you basically get to film a six hour
movie
right the hard part is cutting the stuff
out but in a way it's kind of better
than the movie it sucks i have to wait
each week you know
you are watching it oh and thanks for
that donation rc blue
let's uh let's search it thanks for that
super chat
especially a good one like that uh the
falcon
and the winter soldier there it is uh
okay
oh okay we can watch it now okay let me
set this timer up
if you are all ready to watch the falcon
underwear soldier
we're gonna start going and get your
disney
get your disney pluses ready rc blue
that's a that's awesome thank you so
much for letting me know
came out a little bit early who's ready
because we're going to start i'm
about to do a countdown to start this
and we're going to go
we're going to start watching it uh i
saw something
what can you say about snyder cut uh a
thousand times better than the original
thousand times better than the original
uh i i really loved it and it actually
has one of my favorite superhero scenes
of all time now
probably top five and it's a flash scene
i won't say anything about it it's
amazing you should watch it
all right we're gonna start five four
three two one
i'll start that there
oh actually hold on sorry we're gonna
reset we're gonna reset i should
probably start it
here first all right and go
here we go
well actually if i do the timer i can't
show you guys some scenes so i'm not
going to do the timer
and we'll do we'll do this
actually don't know how i'm showing this
what the heck is going on it's just the
intro right now
all right so we begin we have begun
and i will occasionally show you clips
like this
i can't i can't put this i can't put the
time up because if i put the time up
then i can't show you stuff like this
so i'll just occasionally i'll
occasionally put just kind of like where
i'm at
so i'm at a minute and 26 seconds right
now
uh there are no post credits it is
starting so right now i'm at a minute
a minute and 40. oh it's a black screen
oh oh oh
i didn't mean to move me the falcon and
the winter soldier
is everything good on my on my stream
guys
yeah we're good
what are soldiers so it starts at out as
sam as iron man
it's pretty cool right
so
if you don't want spoilers guys i will
kind of
i will kind of talk about what's
happening because you know it's a watch
party
it's already started right now falcon is
flying through the air
so basically what's happening here is
they they kidnapped
uh they kidnapped
they kidnapped a soldier and they're
about to be an enemy border so basically
sam has to go do it
and same has to do it very covertly
that's the basically sneak and get his
his own troop back
and it's pretty cool it's uh he's going
to this plane
i got dead
uh the episode is already out
uh
we are watching it now [ __ ]
everything so good with the stream
yep okay we're good
uh it's 48 minutes with credits and i
think i determined that it was 42
minutes without credits
so falcons going to get in this plane
because these people have hijacked it
oh there's red wing what up
and um so this is cool seeing red wings
kind of like carving a hole through it
that's pretty cool
all right there's a lot of awesome
fight scenes happening right now it's
pretty legit
i'll try to click to show you guys a few
scenes
freaking epic the action in this is
so cool
so this guy right here he has a the guy
that he's trying to save
has a sword logo on his on his on his
thing
hey what's up malik i'll be bucky that's
fine by me
i can't add a timer and show screen so
here's my screen right now here's where
i'm at
can't add a timer because then i can't
show the screen so i'm sorry about that
and here we go uh
thunderstrucker i would like to think
that but i don't want to start those
rumors
because of all the rumors that we were
talking about
all right here comes freaking here's the
freaking epic scene right here look at
that
and he's going to go and basically just
mess them up
falcons like really cool in this like
they did a really good job
and this whole scene right here is like
insanely cool
uh it is out just search the falcon and
the winter soldier
search it on disney plus and you'll find
it we're watching it right now
right now it's a fight scene it's uh
it's going pretty well
uh squirrel suit sorry i was trying to
think of my name he's flying and chasing
his squirrel suits
and then the helicopters come can agent
coulson show up
i mean he can but he won't to be
perfectly honest he
he's not going to
here goes red wing red wing taken down
helicopters
i'll tell you guys the action in this is
insane it's like such a cool it's so
cool
it's so cool
the description is messed up what do you
mean the description
or so
what description of my video or of
or of the thing
ah everything seems to be good
yes i did hey it's on disney plus ashley
and everybody else watching
aisha it's on disney plus you just have
to search it we're watching it right now
nerd boom
so epic try to show you guys a little
bit of it you know try to try to give
you a little bit
the show is released guys you just gotta
search it
and don't forget we have we have the
discussion after with soups chris and
brad
this scene is insanely cool right here
i wish i could show it to you i wish i
could show the whole thing to you guys
i'm so sorry
maybe one day we could do something like
that well they let us show a whole movie
snyder cut is awesome for those who are
kind of asking
in the description it says one division
watch party really
oh well i can't fix it now that i'm live
i'll change it later
oh this part's insanely cool
got the soldier back boom
it's such a cool such a cool show
such a cool show
i like that the military is so involved
because sam's in the air force
i like that it's so involved alright so
we're in tunisia
now they're chilling
him and torres are chilling
sure
right there
stark level tech
guys just just just search it
just search the falcon and winter
soldier on disney plus
yeah guys i can't change the title at
this point in time at least i don't
think i can change the title at this
point in time
yeah i can't change it right now
flag smashers
jw i wish sharon and bucky would hook up
to
so sam's just talking to a agent torres
who's a military person right now
talking about the flag smashers they
want a world that's unified without
borders
oh this part is so good this part
talking to him about steve
steve rogers
some people think he's in a secret base
on the moon
so you didn't fly captain america up to
the moon no
he's trying to fix red wing
bunny love i'm glad glad you saw
all right so this part for those
watching with me this part this is where
it gets intense
guys we're about talking about spoilers
so if you don't want spoilers
this is the time to click away look who
it is
cameo
we're about to get into some spoilers so
seriously if you don't want any spoilers
for the show
this is time click way
symbols are nothing without the women
and men who give them meaning
and this thing this shield
right it's more about the man who
propped it up
and he's gone
thank you captain america but this
belongs to you
so sam has given up
is giving up the shield he's not taking
it
he's putting it on display in the uh
smithsonian
and they're putting it on the captain
america display
spoilers boom you looking for this
ready i'll teach your nephews how to fly
the right way
cap museum
so he says ready says you can make me
ask
why didn't you take up the mantle
feels like it belongs to someone else
that's someone else's steve
propaganda from captain america the
first avenger
the world's broken so right there you
can actually see
captain america comic that's a real
captain america coming it's actually
captain america
number one um and the cover is him
punching hitler in the face
lots of cool stuff like that in my
breakdown tomorrow
or today today
so for those of you asking spoilers
they never say if cap is dead or not
they never actually say they say he's
gone
but that's so vague that's so vague that
like you could never tell if that
means he went to a different timeline or
he's gone because he's dead or he
chooses to you know
be done hey royal viking
for the netherlands i love the
netherlands
i speak a little dutch expressing [ __ ]
in the airlines
oh all right now we're getting into some
winter soldier stuff
stabbing the face
boom boom
boom
oh
hail hydra i love hearing that
oh bucky oh no
oh
please
oh so we just saw a flashback
of when bucky was the winner soldier and
him
killing people and so he said he just
had a nightmare about that now
he's in therapy and his therapist asks
me she's having a nightmare
and he's like no i'm not having
nightmares nah nah
nah
uh yeah so that's why i said cap is gone
because that's what they say
in the show they don't say he died
they don't say went back to his timeline
like the other timeline they just say
he's gone
they kind of they say like now that
captain america's not here you know it's
like
i wonder if ever you're gonna figure
that out like in this series
all right so here we're finding out that
he has to go to therapy because he's
been pardoned so this
covey accords is not a wanted fugitive
anymore oops i pressed the button
i'm good yes it's out isaiah's
just you gotta type in the falcon in the
winter soldier type it in type it in
type it in
if you search for it you'll find it well
i'm watching her
whoop sorry
so bucky's got a list of people that he
needs to like make amends with
this parts really cool
dirty congresswoman so what does bucky
do about it
he good winter soldiers hey what's up
stripe how's it going
pro pad i don't know how to say that
that's my best that's my best
attempt at your name
rule number two rule number one
nothing illegal rule number two nobody
gets hurt
it's a big rule when making amends
remember me i'm the winner soldier
ah boom right in the face punch
rule number three i'm no longer the
winner soldier
i'm james buchanan barnes bucky
of course i completed
you are part of my efforts to make
amends
but you're getting arrested because
you're evil crook got him
got him he's writing his wrongs
bucky i trust people
give me your phone give me your phone
you don't have 10 phone numbers in this
thing
the only person you've called all week
you're a hundred years old
oh my fancy my mic i'm so sorry
it's just so hot in here i didn't hear
that let me
oh it isn't in my mic i apologize i
think i fixed it
sounds better thank you for telling me
that
so sam is in therapy and he's saying
all i've known is fighting and then he
says with the exception of when he was
in wakanda
what's all he's known
and then he finds out that his therapist
was actually a soldier who
fought and saw a lot of dead bodies
cosmic wonder bucky annoyed me ignored
you
there's a pilot
it's good now cool thanks it's more fire
so he's still just in therapy and
basically what he's saying is you know i
fought my whole life for like
70 years and i fought as a good soldier
then i thought
i fought as the winter soldier
and then i came back fought some more
was in wakanda for a little bit
i thought inventors in game and now you
know it's like nothing
yes they're out you have to go to the
search bar
and type in the falcon and the winter
soldier search for it you will find it
mr nakajima
no
yeah so it is only six episodes but
they're longer than one division
episodes like this is
this is 48 minutes long
and we find out that bucky was ignoring
sam's text messages
and this is kind of important so bucky
has a new friend
and he's saying you should ask out this
waitress that he thinks is cute
she is cute and then his friend mr na
nakagami nagagami nakami
nakami i can't remember his name he'll
say it right here
is it still good
so here's a very important part where he
says my son
nakagimi is
let's talk about his son went overseas
for a job and he was killed and
he never found out why the cops said he
was just in the wrong place at the wrong
time and
i'll never know what really happened to
my son
i thought there's something strange in
here
the show is like it gets intense
so that we were introduced to like kind
of what falcon is doing at the moment
then we're introduced to what bucky's
doing at the moment and now we're
now he's meeting his nephews and a
sister
so sam's back in his family business
visiting his sister his nephews
uh it's out already guys for those
people asking
so i like since i saw this already i
searched
like there's like so many signs and and
stuff like
in this market and i searched it so much
for like easter eggs or clues and
everything
it doesn't seem like there's as many
easter eggs in this show
than one division
so basically sam's family business is in
trouble
for those wondering what time i'm at i'm
at
29 minutes
sam is trying to help his sister fix the
family business because it's not
it's not going anywhere i'm at 30
minutes right
now guys asking for the run oh how long
is run time it's 48 minutes
i'm currently at now 31 minutes
but as i said there's only about 42
minutes of actual
you know footage there's six minutes of
credits there's no end credit scene
either
oh okay so you gotta watch this park
this is like a super intense part it's
like
it kind of like it's good here's bucky
with his date
he brought her flowers because he's so
old school and i love it
if you ever have a date well i don't
know maybe i don't give a girl five
first dates anymore some girls might
think that's really really weird some
girls might find it romantic
so he's on a date right now
he said
he said you tried online dating and it's
weird because there's a lot of weird
pictures out there
and she goes what kind of weird pictures
and he goes tiger pictures
his date goes how old are you and he
goes i'm 106.
and he's
game battleship
they're playing battleship
drinking game every time you get a hit
you drink or every time you get hit you
drink
yuri
oh man
so she's saying it's hard for yori
knowing that his son died
but not knowing how it happened it
messed him up
so now bucky's leaving the date because
because the date was talking about how
yori
is his uh
his son died and doesn't know
so now he's at yori's door
guys big spoilers about to come oh no
no no no
if you don't want spoilers click away
from the stream right now cause i'm
about to talk about what happened
so okay here we go spoilers yori his new
friend
is you know super sad about his son his
son died overseas and he didn't know why
bucky actually killed him when he was
the winner soldier when he was
brainwashed and he's trying to make
amends with them and befriend him but he
can't
he can't like work up the courage to
tell him it's freaking insane
uh prediat um
search it in the search bar search in
the search bar
so sam's just back at his uh sister's
house now
and they're gonna go try to get a loan
for their business
no video games she tells the kids yes
video games oh yeah cat tiger
why don't you put it in the comments
we'll see if you're right
i don't want to imagine if i was
brainwashed by hydra malik
hey i'm on love back to india
i'm going to go there one day hopefully
all right so now we're back to agent
torres and he's got a
he's following the flag smashers and
he's got a secret camera set up here
in his pocket and his zipper that no one
can see
and here it comes they're about to do
something uh there is
no post credits in this one
uh we can i'll go ahead and answer that
question for you new rockstars they're
better than me
but they're a big company and i'm just
me so
i do the best i can but i love eric voss
and i love uh
everybody at new rock stars they're
super awesome
boom flag smasher begins
they're all given these masks and stuff
it's pretty pretty cool
uh no it's not it's not the same
character uh yeah i know the description
says that but i can't change it while
i'm live so
oh
that guy's like super strong yeah
oh he just destroyed this guy on the
ground
destroyed kick to the face oh
yeah no johnny oh this
this guy i know you from somewhere
trying to get a loan from the bank
he's like do i know you falcon's like
come on
then he does this little thing
i knew it falcon
greetings back to belgium
so he's so this guy just said is there
any fun for heroes did stark pay you
or anything like that when he was around
so he said there's a lot of good will
people are inclined
to help
and she says you have had no income over
the past few years and
he says how do you have income if you
don't exist
she was dusted
yeah right lone wolf
this guy said can i get a sofia with
your arms out he's like are you serious
uh william yes that has been confirmed
uh the episode is out we're talking
we're watching it right now
you just gotta search the falcon of the
winter soldier in disney plus
yeah trying to get a loan says i'll go
to every bank in the city to get a loan
it's out already guys we're watching it
right now
so she's basically just saying sam was
dusted you know
but his sister wasn't dusting her kids
weren't she was all alone
you gonna do me like that because you
know i'm right yup
oh i'm sorry that's not available in
nepal uh
posters behind me guardians the galaxy
um from a memorabilia company that i
used to do business with
uh wonder woman i bought online
this is actually from a movie theater
it's like a big
cutout that i'm really glad i have
because you know black panther
ha yeah that was [ __ ] sister not his
mother
uh that's that's unfortunate you guys
don't have it you guys can use vpns
um there's a lot of like free trial vpns
to be able to watch it
it's already out guys we're watching it
right now
and this is pretty much the end he's
looking at flagsmaster footage
he's talking to torres who got his butt
kicked by the flags masters
he's strong
i rock it
come here
yeah i do be a
super soldier all right so this part is
uh
this part's intense guys there's about
to be some spoilers right now so click
away if you don't want them
there's a press conference that they're
watching
and he's saying we need a real person
who embodies america's greatest values
and sam knows what it is
spoilers coming guys hey what's up
monkey
spoilers guys
the united states of america has a new
hero
join me in welcoming welcoming
the new captain america
and there he is new captain
and sam is super hurt
and that's it
there you go that's it right there the
falcon and the winter soldier directed
by kari skoglyn
she was awesome when i talked to her the
whole thing was just super cool
oh such a cool such a cool
[Music]
just everything i mean the show is
really really cool
i personally really really enjoyed this
now let's get into our discussion
there's a lot to talk about guys we're
jumping into the discussion now
so if you don't want to hear any
spoilers
please watch out
um let's
do this
[Music]
let's do this and this and
get into this zoom meeting all right
please wait meeting host will let you in
here we go
people hello
welcome warren what is up
what's up we're back we are back that
week break sucked i missed this
[Laughter]
well do this hold on let me uh fix my
screen so
brad's beautiful face everybody can't
see supes his beautiful face right now
go to his channel supes and you can see
his beautiful face how do i
i guess i just do this yeah there we go
so uh have we all seen it before brad
did you
see it before no this is my favorite
just got that killer freaking awesome
box
yes sir shout out to disney bro um
warren thoughts bro what an episode
what a way to open up the show i think
and this isn't like
this isn't me saying anything bad about
sorry i just realized this is my
microphone not my headset
this isn't me trying to say anything bad
about
one division but this is like marvel
right yeah like from the very beginning
this is like this feels like
marvel and it's totally set up which i'm
fine with
right because i mean it is what it is
but like wow
like the action all the stuff uh yuri's
son
that's like oh my gosh that was that's
so heavy right yeah
it's like so heavy and it's just kind of
like you're like holy crap it's like
that's intense like
what about you guys and that's why i'm
so excited to see buck more bucky stuff
because with the way they opened up this
first episode
they so brilliantly they've set up the
show to the point where
we're gonna see sam and bucky going
throughout this adventure in this
journey together
facing an external threat whether it's
this the flag smashers or zemo
but this in this first episode they
established the internal
conflicts these characters are facing
sam is facing the internal conflict of
feeling worthy enough to take on the
mantle of being captain america
and then buck is facing the internal
conflict of dealing with ptsd
and the sins of his past and it's caught
up to him to present day and
dude when when i when we found out that
he and he
killed rory's son in that winter soldier
flashback scene and it was so great to
see
some winter soldier flashback scenes
so good but uh yeah dude i'm excited to
see how it all
unfolds and how to see how these
characters deal with these individual
internal conflicts as the series
progresses
yeah it's pretty deep like that right i
mean
they're they're gonna and i think as it
goes on they're gonna address a lot more
deeper issues yeah agreed
because wanda was kind of about
depression right in a weird way and like
kind of coping with all that stuff
and if you keep in mind we're like after
right after end game
so much stuff just happened in like the
real life and it's cool that they're
kind of taking like a realistic approach
to this like if this was real life how
would it actually be
yeah that's kind of what they're showing
us and i think that's like
i don't know if ignoring that would be
good
you know what hey did you guys catch uh
i could be reaching here but
when rhodey at the beginning said you
know this is a whole new world
we have allies who've turned to threats
could he be talking about wanda ooh
maybe
um this is this is what six months after
six months after so this will be what
three months after one division
yeah uh uh well one division takes place
three weeks after end game so it'd be
like more like five three weeks sorry i
said months i meant yeah
i meant weeks um
yeah i mean i guess i said i'm curious
when doctor strange multiverse of
madness takes place right
well we got uh no way home first
yeah oh and okay so okay if we go by
that logic
spider-man far from home takes place six
months after right and then no way home
is gonna be immediately after so that's
going to be six months after
so falcon said six months in this
um so it could either be right before
during after you know we don't really
know at this point yeah
maybe brad maybe uh yeah i i want to see
them directly
talk about it whether it's like a
soldier telling sam about
what happened in in west view or or
bucky
who knows man i just want them to see at
least hint at it like
to and just to lean on what makes this
universe so strong which is the inner
connectivity of it
so like to have all of the events that
went down in in
one division i would love to see them
just at least like mention it at least
once but i do love how already off the
off the
jump we're starting to see the impact of
the events of the snap
and the events of end game and seeing
how that impacted like
sam's sister in her life financially yes
and uh
it dude it was great to see and i just i
love how they're finally addressing that
because we didn't get to see that
in spiderman far from home we didn't
really see that in one division
so now we're seeing the impacts of the
all of those events from those five
years
and it it's it's awesome to see well and
that's actually i love that you said
this i said that today
in my like non-spoiler review um
because the director said kerry skoglin
said that
if avengers end game was like this huge
magical
big blown up you know otherworldly thing
falcon and winter soldier is the
grounded show like
you know when he's like you have no
proof of income for the last five years
and it's like
how does somebody have income if they
don't exist you know it's just yeah like
and he's like well you know people are
popping back up and it's like the very
real thing that like
well yeah everyone's popping back up and
they don't work and they haven't had a
job so everyone's asking for loans so
like we had to change things we can't
ask for loans anymore you know we're not
giving them away
as easy because things are like crazy
and it's just kind of like you don't
really think about
i've never thought about that i mean
i've thought about stupid stuff like oh
the people who got dusted from planes
and come back do they fall to their
death you know
it's kind of like those are the stuff i
thought about but then you think about
it's like
what is the single mother with her kids
who all survived
you know that's hard especially when
you're
your brother who was an avenger you know
kind of helped with things and stuff
like that it's like
dang that's pretty deep like that's
pretty
real world problems real world yeah it's
real world um
what do you think uh sam was alluding to
when he was on the phone with his
his guy and he made some like
small comment like super soldier 100
yeah okay
yeah i i think i think you don't think
he's a
i think that's i believe that's what he
said and
i would say yeah super soldier for sure
because yeah agreed yeah before i even
like that scene happened when i first
watched it and they're like kicking
people around i'm like okay these are
super soldiers obviously yeah um
especially
like if it was in a different um show
then i would say i don't know but since
it is you know
basically a spin-off of captain america
i i would i would say super soldier
yeah and that would be that would
definitely be something that
that would definitely give sam a reason
to go contact bucky
because they're dealing with the super
soldier serum that's a really good point
too
yeah who's been avoiding sam
hey it's chris kind of going on
everybody
no it's me it's me i'm here hello
i hear you okay cool what's up guys
i don't think a lot of people knew that
you could watch it right now how fast
did you guys watch it were you searching
it in the beginning
uh no we were just we we were ready we
were ready
i wonder what time it actually came out
and then no it came out
like 20 minutes early okay because i
watched it like 10 minutes really i
think or something like that
yeah i got in like 12 like i think i
started watching it uh
38 so so guys here's the question
do we start
theorizing and starting the rumors
[Laughter]
my first question is this is steve dead
or is he not i don't think he's not the
biggest
dead
that's what so many people asked me in
my day at the beginning
yeah some people were asking my tattoo
is cop dead dude i don't think cap's
dead i think
in order for the world to just uh i
think that's just the official narrative
that they're going with i agree
not explain that cap is old now and he's
like an old guy who's retired
but the steve rogers that everyone knew
and loved that fun end game he's not
around anymore so
i think that's just like the official
narrative they're going with and that's
that why
the episode kind of started with a cap
memorial plus
i feel like if cap was really dead
marvel would have given us a way better
funeral
yeah and we would have known that he was
dead
yeah i feel like that too they wouldn't
have passed up on that uh sentimental
opportunity for sure yeah exactly
no funeral cap's not dead he'll show up
somewhere eventually
[Music]
i wouldn't be surprised if he shows up
like somewhere in this series like
maybe yeah sam sam might need a little
bit of guidance or something and he'll
show up
well wasn't there oh this was such
a long time ago i don't even recall what
exactly it said i don't call this a
rumor or a
report by an insider something like that
that was saying like oh cap's going to
return
to basically what you just said like
mentor
the new captain because okay so here's
another
so we're introduced to uh u.s agent at
the end
new captain america fake captain
america's a lot of people are uh
calling it in my uh yeah he's a capper
hashtag not my cap
i love him hashtag not my cat i just
like not my cop in the shot let's go
i'm tweeting that right now he's a fake
i love it
hashtag not my cap oh my gosh that's
awesome
my cap that's epic brad
[Laughter]
oh my gosh that's pretty cool um but
but okay so we know that he gets the
shield or we know the falcon gets the
shield back at some point right
yes indeed so
this is where like okay theories come in
right so does
does does falcon fight him and just take
it back is he good is he bad
is he being brainwashed via a super
soldier serum which i
i think i think that might be the case
uh that's what i've heard
oh dude that was one of the more
interesting things that uh uh that's
because sam gave up the shield at the
beginning of the episode
now dude in all of the marketing we've
seen sam with that shield
yeah like i dude i expected the show to
open up with him
training with the shield yeah so like
we're still gonna get to see that but
uh i talked to i talked with someone
else who had seen the episode earlier
on and we were speculating that like
that could be like
towards the end of the show like
epilogue kind of thing like
the show ends with sam training as the
new captain america
and uh bucky's there you know he's there
he's just there with bucky but
i don't know it was just it was kind of
weird to see the the route that they
went because it was it was
it went in the completely opposite
direction that i thought they were going
in yeah
also chat you know they're making us
agent look like a total dweeb for a
reason
oh right to make it look innocent
harmless
just like a total fraud right
i mean i think that's intentional
because
obviously they're not gonna have someone
come in and just be
as cool as uh steve so um
i i kind of like the fact that he looks
to weeby and i honestly wouldn't be
surprised if he goes out there and gets
completely wrecked
right so you know he's like the mandarin
yeah
yeah yeah yeah well okay so i will say
this um
yesterday yesterday the day before maybe
today heck i don't know all these days
run
run together now um marvel did release
an official photo of john walker
in his military uniform correct so
you know maybe i i so
to start the rumors this is
this is what i think could be happening
i i do think thunderbolt ross is
involved somehow
if the super soldier serum is involved
he was so involved with the sokovia
accords he was so
involved um you know with the super
soldier program in the beginning he's
not
like an okay guy right like we kind of
know that um
bringing back the weapon plus program
which is the weapon x program blah blah
blah blah
i think maybe this guy has ptsd
maybe he's hurt or something like that
and they kind of just say like
we can turn you into the next captain
america and what would you say yeah of
course
give me the super soldier serum that
made puny little steve rogers
big superman and yeah of course i want
to be the new captain america of course
i want to be the new captain america you
know what i'm saying it's like
i think something like that is going on
whether it's ross or something like that
i i think we will probably see that he's
gonna have some type of super soldier
serum and i wonder if that's going to
be some type of brain control or
something like that but i think he
what i what i would like to see i guess
was him
he was a good guy maybe he's got some
ptsd because that seems to be a pretty
big theme of this
and you know people who believes are
good or bad manipulate him and
maybe he starts to become bad because of
some things
and eventually sam's gonna
shield somehow right i mean yeah we see
all the trailers he has the shield
so he just steals it does sam take the
serum
i don't think i don't yeah i don't think
so
but uh i i do think we're gonna get a
lot of stuff with uh
u.s agent and bucky you know these are
both two characters that
i think were again bucky's dealing with
his ptsd
i think we're definitely gonna see u.s
agent like deal with ptsd to a certain
extent yeah
i don't think he's all there necessarily
i mean we have we just got introduced to
the character
but uh um seeing like some of the photos
that they've released of john walker
uh i just i have a feeling that he's
gonna be
in that same mental space where he's not
gonna be he's not gonna be in a healthy
state of mind and uh i think we're we
might
even see bucky try to help him cope with
his ptsd and that's how
bucky ends up coping with his own ps
ptsd by helping someone else cope with
it
yep maybe i mean that's yeah i mean that
that's a real thing
i think i'm definitely leaning towards
hoping this has something to do with the
thunderbolts that black widow comes out
and we see thunderbolts ross is getting
the serum and whether it works
completely or not
and it ends up leaning towards you know
that team coming together because i
think it'd be really cool to see a group
of anti-heroes just
bawling yeah
i don't think they're setting it up just
yet no but they're definitely starting
to push it i think
and i hope that's how we end up yeah for
sure daddy thank you for that super chat
uh
i don't know if he's onto the playing
smashers rather than he's just trying to
trying to um contact him because they
both showed kepler his friends hey can
you guys hear me right now
can you hear me oh so much love
homie i will catch you guys next time
next week next week welcome friday let's
do it uncle friday
friday soups chris
something i want to talk about there
seems to be a lot less hype for the show
i agree there's a lot less hype but i
think that's because of the name
i think people hear falcon and the
winter soldier and they think sidekicks
and they don't yet see them as you know
the core avengers and you think about
everything no
no dude exactly it's it's not it's not
that
hold up wait wait wait i'm like adding
you back in here oh hi
uh oh go ahead bro you know why there's
less hype for the show
let's hear it why is that burger thank
you so much thank you thank you so much
for that super chat
that's possible i you know what yeah
like even after this episode like
like we all could be talking about like
thunderbolts and uh and
all of this different stuff but like
even i don't want to talk about it
because it's crazy
but yeah i don't want to experience the
same thing we experienced
when nothing happened in one division so
like
you know with this with this series
we're kind of taking the approach of
like all right let's just sit back
relax enjoy the show instead of like one
edition where one of the mission was
just like a mystery box giving us all
these different things
that could that could lead to all these
different theories coming true
so now again because no one's theorizing
anymore and we're just waiting to see
how big marvel's waiting to go on disney
plus yeah
that's why i don't think the hype is as
big as it was with one vision
well screw it i'll do it i'm not afraid
i'll theorize
that's what i that's what i do that's
what we all do that's what we do
that's what we do and i'm sorry you know
it
it's kind of weird because it's like the
people are like you said this were going
to happen it's just kind of like
are you mad because you wished it did
i'm sorry i don't write the show
like i get it we you can't blame us
for you can't blame us for you know
i don't want to say we're like writing a
better show but you can't blame us for
having these like
out of the box ideas yeah these crazy
big dreams that that
that are just pure fan service for us
that we would all go
crazy over like this is what we do as
fans we theorize we come together
and uh not and and all of the theories
we have for one division like made sense
it wasn't like
right freaking out it wasn't like oh
x-men are going to show up at the end
right no
they all had evidence with the the
things that the cast were saying
with the the easter eggs that they were
dropping in the show like
are you kidding me a grim reaper helmet
like
random division
that was undeniable there was a
featurette with
freaking would you wonder about it and
it never happened
they do this stuff on purpose but
so it's really weird because i kind of
feel like this is more of a
straightforward show but at the same
time exactly
but at the same time i don't know who it
was i read an article
and i read the quote he was like one of
the writers producers or something was
asked about like you know all these
crazy theories and he said
well there might be even more for this
show
so yeah i i can't see that i just can't
see that just because it's such
it's so much more of a grounded story
it's a lot more straightforward 100
it is more straightforward but if you
take into
account the fact that kevin feige i
think
yesterday in an interview
said that there's a place they visit in
this show they did that they didn't have
access
to before the fox merger and that has to
be major poor
you know um yeah and obviously magic
board has that
huge connection to the x-men so it's
like
now we're gonna start to say you know uh
do you have a mutant show up and i i'm
actually going to go ahead and throw
this out now
i think there are always should be
reference referenced
i don't think we'll see more than one if
it happens
or maybe we will they won't tell us
right if they're just like in magipore
and we see people maybe they'll be
mutants that'll be revealed later on
but just based off how grounded the show
really is i do
think that they're going to keep so it's
like one division you know how they were
like
we came up with all these theories that
made a lot of sense but it actually took
it away from the story
i think they're going to do the same
thing here i think they'll focus on the
story
yeah that's one thing coming out of one
division that uh
i personally wasn't affected by all the
theories i was super satisfied
hey musa's descendant the vibe is much
more grounded in the real everyday world
like how marvel necklace shows were
slower than i expected but it's got
potential
yeah i mean it was a setup and thank you
so much for that uh
for that super chat but you know it was
it's the beginning
i think it's going to get really good
the action sequences were really good
um they were really really good
but you know they obviously have to do
some setting up
it does happen because i feel like with
the way this first episode went and the
way
the with the way like we saw sam kind of
dealing with the idea of becoming the
next cat
and having that pressure and not feeling
worthy to wield that shield
yeah i think it's gonna be such such
more of a uh it's gonna be a way bigger
payoff in the long run
once he does kind of just like own it
yeah yeah
i mean we need to think back to the
beginning of marvel back phase one
you know you think of the first time you
saw iron man suit up how cool that was
the first time you saw captain america
hold a hold the shield the first time
the core avengers in the first avenger
movies in the middle of new york
they had that pano circle around them
and they were standing there these were
really simple moments they had huge
payouts
for us as fans but now we've been so
spoiled with infinity war and end game
and
you know 60 different characters on the
screen at once that
we maybe aren't so satisfied with the
little payouts anymore
but we got to look forward to those in
order to enjoy this rebuilding phase of
the mcu or else we're going to be
miserable for the next
five years waiting for 80 people to be
on screen at once
yeah and especially after one division
for sure i'm just uh before we
before i get back to those like crazy
wow theories because we could all just
sit here and talk about how like
wolverine could potentially show up in
madrid right to some extent
but uh for me i'm just kind of taking a
a
a a chill approach to the show because
i'm just waiting to see how marvel
is how big marvel's willing to go on
disney plus
like one regardless of how one vision
ended and i do think it was a good
ending it was a satisfying ending
especially for the character of scarlet
witch for sure
as good as that ending was we can all
agree that that show could have been way
bigger than it was
oh yeah it could have been way bigger
than it was well that takes me back to
kind of what i just said we
thought bigger and then
marvel went well no we're just we just
want to talk about wanda
you know what i mean like yeah
and then this guy and bring in doctor
strange for the final fight as well and
blah blah blah blah
when when they were really like hey it's
it's called the one division show
we told you the title yeah we're gonna
talk about one division and i think it's
gonna be the same thing here
i think there's gonna be some cool
cameos like you know roadie showing up
which
which made sense because he is in the
air force
right this is a national thing
um he's a high ranked air force as well
he knew captain america is an avenger
it just made sense on that note
i noticed something this time around
when we were watching it and um
he was really pushing for sam to maybe
take that shield back he was
so i wonder if maybe he knew he's like
dude if you don't take it they're gonna
give it to someone like
if he he's in on in on it a little bit
all right blue thanks so much for that
super chat again um
i don't know i think they might try to
keep it i think they might try to keep
it focused on sam i don't think he's
going anywhere anytime soon so
it's a possibility but i'm gonna go and
said no say no right off top of my head
just a thought i don't know if that'll
pay out to anything or not but was just
something that went across my mind
yeah definitely
so you could tell the beginning when
he's getting dressed like what first
minute of the episode
it's like the first thing yeah he's
looking at the shield same bag the
captain gave him the shield in
same bag same bag
you could tell on his face he was he was
struggling
with the decision to give it up
but captain america was his hero
right so you have to remember that you
know
captain america was his captain america
too right and so he's kind of
and he's kind of said it you know
several times the first episode like i
don't want
to take that mantle because it's not
mine right if the shield feels like
somebody else's because it's captain
america's right
so ugh i
there's just so many ways that this ship
could go i
but i i think by the i i think he thinks
it means one thing
right to him and then as things change
it's going to mean something else
and that's when i think he's going to
think it's okay to
to take on that mantle right because
right now he's kind of thinking like
yeah captain america was my best friend
i don't want that mantle that was his
man that was my boy like
captain you know what i'm saying like he
was my captain too i don't want to yeah
who am i to replace him right pretty
much like and i want to honor him right
because you know what would you want to
do with your friend like you'd want to
honor him
so it's like i'm not going to take his
title but i think by the end yeah
his mind might change and say i want to
take it to honor him
yeah that's pretty yeah and uh with the
way this episode ended
like it became it just became personal
for sam oh
oh his face at the end he was devastated
it just became personal for sam that
shield means
so much to him and you know knowing that
steve kind of know in a very similar way
that like tony stark left the edith
glasses to peter parker
specifically for peter parker yeah steve
steve left that shield for sam
specifically for
sam you did so now this just became
personal for sam and i want to see i'm
that's why i'm so excited for next
episode because i want to see sam
you know take it upon himself to go get
that shield back because
it's going to be like kind of the way
same way peter parker realized that
yvd productions i am curious as well
thank you so much for that super chat
i'm very curious i want to see
and i think they're going to address it
more
musas descended that's hilarious they
are geniuses
i agree and i think you know
he gave up the shield but it was his to
give up and nobody else's
right yeah it seemed like if he wanted
it he could have had it oh a hundred
percent
they didn't take it from him right but
just like soup said
it's personal now because sam because
sam if i'm sam
i'm like captain gave me that choice
right so if i'm not captain america
which is my decision
nobody's going to be captain america
right and that was what he wanted
right because he gave that shield up
because he didn't want that mantle taken
from his friend
because he even said that in his speech
he's like you know the shield's a symbol
but it's the man behind
it right so to him it's not about that
title
it was about steve so in his mind he's
going steve is captain america
nobody else is i'm not taking it because
nobody else is captain america
so now he's pissed like soup said he's
pissed it's personal
so yeah it's it's personal uh i'm i'm
hyped to see
the the action in the next episode well
the action was insane so action was
insane so many cool things it was
cinematic too you know
some people are thinking like oh you
know it's a yeah 150 million
rumored but probably true budget for six
episodes you know it's like that's
insane
so it's gonna it's gonna be insane uh
the the fighting
from here on out is gonna be ridiculous
and i'm curious about zemo i'm really
curious about zemo yeah how does zemo
play into all of this
well so yeah that's what i was trying to
figure out too where does he fit in
well sorry black smashes
well axe masters so check this out so i
interviewed the director charlie
scotland i specifically asked about zemo
because i was specifically wondering
about him
and she said she was very vague but she
said whatever you expect out of him
it's not going to happen the opposite's
going to happen so i'm sitting there
like
what well i would expect him to turn on
them
well but he's so here's here's my
thought process
in the trailers he's you know he's bad
right no more superheroes and stuff like
that i can't allow these people to
exist so i would expect him to and i
think most people would expect him to
finish his work go against the avengers
go against bucky and sam
but the opposite of that or what you're
not expecting is for him to work with
them and
actually in the trailers when they're
walking into madrid they're all together
so yeah so here they're definitely
together at some point
right so my theory is
maybe he sees that like falcon and bucky
are good
uh bucky's no longer brainwashed and
there's hope right but
the flax masters are super soldiers and
his whole deal is against the super
soldier so let's unite and take down the
super soldiers
yeah yeah yeah for sure right i mean
yeah
yeah i yeah i agree and and again in the
trailer
this is something we've seen multiple
times of like them working together so
yes alejandra escalante
keep an open mind thank you for that
super chat i appreciate that
yeah uh that's kind of what i think
might
be happening here right he doesn't
necessarily like the avengers try to
take them all out but
i what you know he was really against
bucky as the super soldier
uh yeah as the super because i think if
you look at captain america
you're not going to be like stupid super
soldiers like they're so evil you can't
say that right
he's looking at bucky and the others
that were trained by hydra
right so i think when he's gonna see
bucky good
and then you know maybe reminisce a
little bit about how captain was good
he's going to realize that it's not
necessarily superheroes that are the
problem
it's the super soldiers being made into
weapons
and then they'll team up and go against
that
yes yeah that'd be actually really cool
i like that idea
so guys with that being said i'm gonna
for sure sorry sorry to cut you off
board but i'm gonna i'm gonna head out
i'm gonna go get some sleep go film some
videos i checked out my cap
not mike
hashtag rory's the goat hashtag rory's
the goat
got her bro got her boy
with a beautiful bucky yeah where is
that guy first episode what is happening
oh wait i got rory before you leave
sleeps then before you leave does he get
with a girl at the end
uh i think there's a higher chance that
he probably gets with sharon
than that girl i'd like that too i'd
like that about that all right cool
boys nice soups good to be back
it's good to be back we'll see you guys
next week see you guys next week happy
birthday guys
peace
all right let's just bring it back
well
i hope everybody liked it of course as
you know the first episode
so of course they're gonna you know set
it up but i think the action was amazing
i thought the story was amazing that was
pretty intense
uh alejandro again thank you so much for
that super chat i know i missed one more
bumbo jazzy what's up man welcome back
kevin finding the past interviews spoke
by dizzy plus telling stories of
characters
in the main characters i'm not sure we
will see mutants phase four
um so so i think we will but i don't
know if they'll like straight up say
their mutants right um
this isn't me trying to like start
rumors this is
legitimate thinking of mine if they're
going to if
they're going to explore the super
soldier program
that is connected to the weapons plus
program which thunderbolt ross
had a big hand in kind of brought back
that's connected to the weapons x
program which is responsible for
deadpool and wolverine and a bunch of
other
mutants there's connections there
that i don't think will really come to
fruition in
this show but i think will set things up
kevin downey thanks so much for that
super chat maybe zemo took out
the avengers in his own grief but has
worked through it now
like wanda yeah um
i think that's a good chance that that
that might be
what's happening like i kind of just
said um
you know maybe he realizes like you're
saying works through his own grief maybe
he kind of realizes that
you know i hated the winter soldier i
hated the brainwashed person
who hydra a super evil organization
right
made him but i don't hate bucky
right because bucky is a good person he
was you know in the army and he fought
with steve and
you know kind of lost in war hydro found
him and made him into the winter soldier
so i think
maybe he goes you know it wasn't
actually bucky who did or
yeah it wasn't actually bucky who did
this it was the winter soldier and
i hate the winter soldier not him and
then i i do think
at the end when he was talking about uh
when taurus was like you don't think
and sam's like you know i'll get back to
you um
i do think he was gonna say you don't
think he's a super soldier
because they were obviously insanely
strong um
i don't think they're mutants i don't
think the flagsmasters are mutants so
then you have to ask
how are they so strong and he says in
the commercial you know
think they're part of the big three
androids aliens wizards
source cerebral and all that stuff
that's great commercial
but um i don't think they're mutants
i don't think they're androids or aliens
i i think they're super
i think they're experiments i think the
flag smashers are people who want
those walls taken down in unity within
the world so they kind of volunteer
to have all the stuff done and you know
it's a super soldier program and
i think that's what it is and i think
we're gonna see that come
come to light so all right guys
i thought this was awesome um
i kind of been saying i've enjoyed it
more than one division but it's very
different than one division
i love the wand division for a lot of
different things i love this for a lot
of different things
um i love the action the falcon scene
was like fantastic i really
liked it had a lot of emotion um
it was funny and i talked about some
some
things that i think needed to be talked
about what
what was life like in the blip which i
think was is going to be
addressed more what
what is it like now that people are back
how do superheroes get paid right stuff
like that it's just kind of like you
know did
did stark you know pay you guys you know
stuff like that starts gone
um there's a lot of cool things
addressed in this
um if i had to rate this episode
probably like an 8 out of 10
um only because it's like
the pilot episodes the first episode
they had to set things up
um i don't think there was any bad
scenes
uh a a lot of it was necessary but i
probably could have had
i don't know i you know i think it had a
good amount of action i think it
balanced out really well so
yeah i'll say like uh eight or nine out
of ten so let's just go eight and a half
let's say like eight and a half out of
ten i think it was pretty pretty
pretty dang good and the only reason i'm
not going to give it a 10
is because i think the other episodes
are gonna be
better because you have zemo and sharon
carter
and all these other people showing up
you as agent we're gonna really get into
it so
i'm gonna go ahead and say eight and a
half out of ten
because i think we're about to get some
nine out of tens and ten out of 10's and
i think it's gonna be really
good and remember there's only six
episodes but they're longer right this
was already
about as long as the longest one
division episode right so
i think we're in for a good run with
this show i really do i really think
we're
in for a good run with the show so
having said that i'm gonna get to work
start working on some videos my
breakdown um
since i saw the first episode before
i've kind of already done my breakdown
so there's just some editing and stuff
to go through so i would expect my
breakdown of this probably within like
four hours that sounds good
so all right guys thank you all so much
for everybody who showed up today i love
doing these we took a week off now we're
back i'm glad everybody's back here
i think i think people are gonna really
like like this show i think
it's gonna go in a good direction so
look out for my video in about
four hours of everybody set up or when
you wake up be sure to check it out
i've already found a lot of easter eggs
like comic books like real life comic
books
inside of the mcu right now it's pretty
cool so
there's some cool stuff and i'll explain
everything that needs to be explained so
i will see you guys next week this time
live watch party falcon in the winter
soldier episode 2.
uh it started a little early today so
i'll make an announcement on youtube
i'll put it like community post or
something like what time we'll probably
start this
because it'll probably start like 20
minutes earlier
um for those talking about the snyder
verse
snyder vs the sniper cut it was awesome
i highly recommend watching zack
snyder's justice league because
truly was awesome um really really
really enjoyed it it has one of my
favorite superhero scenes a flash scene
in it towards the end of the film
was super awesome so all right guys
gonna get going
so you